thank you so much first of all one quick
thing to say which is very important now
before I start I would like to thank
professor sweat mr. David Amram and
Herjavec him for being here with me
tonight all the Center for jazz studies
everybody in there because otherwise
these would have not been possible and
the state university of milan and my
tutors there because this project is
part of a fellowship that I got there so
I need to thank also my University in
Italy now what I would like to do is
since I'm Italian and at times I screw
up with language and I decided to create
a PowerPoint in order to show you some
of the things that I've found now the
quick story of my research is I've been
working at the bird collection and I'm
thinking also everybody there because
they're being very patient with me on
the manuscript that Jack Eric wrote on
jazz that have never been published
before it's a corpus that contains
everything from essays to fragments in
Diaries journals to think that were
published but maybe in small magazines
or magazines that were not so very well
distributed or minority sort of
magazines and and also essays and short
stories that were hidden in personal
journals but that never saw the light
out of a major publication so one of the
things that I noticed is that in this
corpus describes a new Kerouac a Care
Act that is only a parent you know if
you analyze all of the published
material and it can become clear through
the analysis of the unpublished material
now in the material that I've analyzed
there is something that is pretty
interesting and ridiculous which sums up
what was the reaction towards Jack
Herrick and jazz in the 50s when he was
writing about jazz and now in escapades
jazz pub at Carrick published the birth
of bebop and the editor who published
the birth of bebop declared that he
hadn't understood a thing
the essay and so he wanted to have some
comments from the public about it and
that they would have given $100 to the
best in favor of Carrick letter and the
best against Carrick letter now as you
can see this is one of the letters that
was written with regard to that
bebop essay and as we you can say you
can see on screen in approaching Jack
Harris writing about Jeff it seems there
is no alternative but to begin by
admitting that he knows nothing about
the subject I say this with the certain
Tsar and at the same time great
eagerness and so on so really quite a
negative connotations given to Kerouac
but what is even worse is that it goes
on by saying playing jazz requires
technical ability intelligence thoughts
and very special temperament mr. Kirk's
writing requires nothing but gall and
the first sentence in Kirk's escapade
article says that both began with jazz
since Bob is jazz this is equivalent to
saying that cars began with auto
Mobile's it makes no sense so as you can
see quite a negative reaction to his
writing by a very young student of you
know who was an English major and
trumpet player on the other hand there
were positive reactions by also
musicians who understood that what
Carrick was trying to do with that
article was not only creating a very
historical analysis of bebot but rather
describing bebop in a way that sounded
also like bebop so this student who won
the context says however at the
beginning of bob by mr. Carrick i doubt
that many readers who read the article
seriously failed to find themselves
immersed in the smooth flowing
improvisational river of this article
perhaps one does not understand the
article per se but one does acquire a
more complete understanding of bob and
as a music student I have had my fill of
cold factual accounts of music and its
history mr. Kirk's article is Bob this
is a refreshing and truly valid
description of a movement in jazz that
has been extremely important in the
development of the idea
I believe that jazz cries out for
spokeman such as mister Kerouac only
through a style such as this can anyone
hope to describe the essence of jazz on
the printed page and some readers may be
appalled at the unconventional ISM an
occasional lack of punctuation a jazz
chart is not usually impeccably
punctuated either the punctuation is in
the mind in my mind the understanding is
that Kerik has written a vivid word
picture of the beginning of Bob and now
as you can see we have two opposite
reactions and this sums up a little bit
of what was the critical reaction of
Jack Eric's writings on jazz of the
following years and even today we have
they're too extreme and opposed
reactions one extremely negative that
says that at times he is not correct
when he quotes factual elements then he
is not specific and that he prefers to
focus on the language as being jazz
language in jazz poetry rather than on
the content now this is also because
what was not published is a lot or was
not as distributed as the novels and the
poems is what he actually wrote more
specifically on jazz for example his
first early writings on jazz as you can
see Steve Turner's quotes the interview
to George Avakian in Nick's Jack's club
during an afternoon set by Maxie Spanier
and he wrote an appreciation of Count
Basie called the last world in hot music
and then with the papers editor Morten
Maxwell managed an interview with Glenn
Miller backstage at the Paramount
Theater so when it was at the Horace
Mann School he actually wrote very
specific things on jazz the problems
that they were not as well distributed
as the other material that were the
novels for example or the poems and with
regards to the unpublished material that
I have found I've decided to let these
material speak rather than to comment
too much on it because it's material
that is has not been distributed so it's
new to our eyes
and it speaks by itself now in April
1947 Carrick wrote at an excerpt an
essay entitled new modern progressive
jazz the new bebop and he describes
bebop as follows this new change
tremendous kind of step forward in
rhythmic harmonic and melodic ideas
requiring the abilities of the finest of
jazz musicians for proper expression has
taken jazz jazz with its once seemingly
so infinite yes its stablished
set and concluded identities and given
it a brilliant new power and beauty that
makes everything which has come before
it seems obsolete and limited jazz now
seems from the vantage point of today
and its latest developments to have
undergone three major ears
the Dixieland first with its two four
tempo and church chord idea the busy
Lankford Goodman second year with its
4/4 tempo and increasing harmonic and
melodic development and sophistication
and subtlety of expression and the new
bebop Gillespie era making a complete
break from anything else before knowing
that the rhythm the beat is no longer
the primary vehicle of the musical idea
nor the principle impact of the
expression and harmony and melody are
developed word scale now we can say
everything but but that this is not
enough specific enough for the audiences
that were criticizing him for talking
and focusing too much about the style
and the homophone ease and the
alliterations rather than the content so
with regards to this for example he says
where is just going the last section is
depression asked by those whose
conception of jazz remains fixed within
3 1944 limits of rhythmic harmonic
contrapuntal and melodic understanding
so it does show that he had an
understanding of how big pop was
breaking the rules of what previously
jazz was now another essay that i found
that found particularly interesting in
this analysis
an essay that has never been published
dedicated to the evolution between
American classical music and jazz so
starting from the point of view that
jazz could influence American classical
music and turn American classical music
into a form of art almost completely
independent from the European forms and
from the European formats of what
classical music should be now in this
essay he says the whole meaning of
American jazz is contained in this New
Orleans band went for the first time
rather than as a super imposition upon
European classic forms as in for Jack
McDowell Gilbert American music emerged
in itself straining at the traditional
forms breaking them instantly incredibly
and smashing forth on its own the Jazz
Age of the 20s with its Joss Stone
singers and Gershwin composers is an
assimilated process of the New Orleans
miracle it cannot be understood without
its roots Gershwin could not have
acquired D sometimes graceful sometimes
singing sometimes even nostalgic
lyricism without some contact with the
particularly singing forms of jazz music
and then it goes on describing the
differences of forms and of rhythms also
that influenced American classical music
again a much more knowledgeable kind of
critic that certain scholars have
allowed to him to be in their analysis
of Jack Eric's writings because probably
because also they had no access to this
material which shows a new care work now
another element which is interesting and
which luckily is more evident in in the
novels and is how he wanted to write
with a bob prosody now in his essential
of spontaneous prose Garrick says that
he would like to write as a jazz
musician it plays so using breath as one
of the key rhythms of his writings and
he was amazing in his use of Omaha
needle iterations and rhythmical
elements in the writings of the jazz
sessions of end excerpts of the novels
but there are some fragments of his
journals that are
also even more amazing from this point
of view now if you read and consider how
this sounds
this short fragments on Dizzy Gillespie
you realize that he chose certain
consonants in certain vowels not only
because they sounded cool but because
they actually sounded bought bebop so
that named Dizzy Gillespie that name of
the founder of the most unity and jazz
yet is so act and floss destiny for
bebop is dizzy Tunisian and wild dizzy
himself is a unique fellow eager
excitable curious warm and violent he
wants nice cat calorie in the ass with a
razor I heard him in an interview shy
stammering brilliant hearing fro
fiercely excited he has all the
contradictions of a genius not
temperament but to motor straights he's
playing and the whole style dizzily
races after ideals in a tumultuous
rhythmical frenzy so much that rhythm is
almost abolished all you hear is the
drum emphasis while the harmonies always
race race dizzy and possess and met and
the ideas are diseased the phrasing is
almost unbelievably fast and subtle
dizzy
again it's a very emotional description
that nonetheless really uses language in
order to reproduce the rhythm that is
the last view was actually playing now
we have tons of experts like these ones
but now I would like to consider another
of the elements that by the critics that
were against Jay Garrick and jazz has
been analyzed only up to a certain point
and I would like you to see an excerpt
if I managed to close this okay
of a movie that Jack Kerouac did
directed by Alfred Leslie and Robert
Frank with the music written by person
that we are so lucky as to have here
tonight yes David Amram and there is a
gem session that I would like to show
you in the middle of the movie and
please pay attention to the first person
that you will see on screen because you
will recognize mr. Ammer
if I was holding the world holy his
glasses holy this time blame is all the
white night only empty room some we
kneel holy come on Bishop tell us boy
holy Byzantine holy Marco ladies
American flag holy is girl holy it's
your sister holy that is holy holy holy
holy holy holy and car holy and light
holy is holy holy I see that I think
it's best I go now go make my holy
offices
you know what I mean
these guys on being a vegetable that's
the bond with the other cats over there
talking and right someone you're doing
something something good by doing
something and saying goodbye and saying
goodbye and doing something about the
same do you really have to leave no
don't leave and he says just comes to
spectacle this is I really don't want
you to leave I think now having says yes
hey there Tara miles attend Blueboy they
all sit on my lap because you can't
sleep anymore
what are you doing up this only I know
what you want and I'll play by one he's
alright let's go
now to go back to our lure as you can
see we have mr. Amram here who is also
in this picture and who wrote the score
for who my daddy and he helped Kerouac
who had lived and narrated the movie
when it was finished in a sort of
improvised ad just poetry version so
these are the words that mr. M gave him
and in an interview with evergreen
review basically in the spring of 1959
the poom-poom idea was made
Allen Ginsberg Gregory Corso Peter loves
killed Larry rivers and myself the third
Avenue all stars as one we described us
appeared in it Alfred Leslie directed it
and Robert Frank filmed it
Jack had written the scenario and after
the film had been edited Jack saw it
because it was a silent movie Jack was
to narrated and I was to write the music
afterwards he ellen and neal cassady
also wrote the lyrics for the title song
to my daddy for which I wrote the music
and which was sung in the film by Anita
Alice Jack put on earphones and asked me
to play so that it could improvise the
narration to music the way had done at
our readings
he watched the film and made up the
narration on the spot he did it two
times through spontaneously and that was
it he refused to do it again
he believed in spontaneity and the
narration turned out to be the very best
thing about the film we recorded it at
Jerry Newman's studio there was an old
friend of Jack's from the early 40s and
afterwards we had a party jam session
that lasted all night Jack played the
piano sang and improvised for hours